[Musik]
Kreativität muss nicht aufhören, nur
Heavy Metal zu singen, du weißt, wenn deine
Stimme verändert wurde, so dass du
nicht mehr so singen konntest, wie du früher gut s
ngen konntest, vielleicht könntest du ander
singen, wenn du '  Wenn Sie fliegen, machen Sie sich
nur Sorgen um das Flugzeug, weil
das Flugzeug das ist, was alle
schützt. Die meisten Piloten, wenn Sie mit
ihnen sprechen und denken, oh, Sie sind ein
Linienpilot, was ist mit all diesen Leuten, und
sie sagten, vergiss diese Leute, was ist
mit mir da?  das hat fast ein Gefühl von
Ritual und dieses Ritual macht
alles zu einem sicheren Ort für das Publikum,
weil sie alle eine gemeinsame Sprache teilen
, nämlich die Musik und die Erfahrung
, zu einem Fußballspiel zu gehen,
aber Fußballspiele können ziemlich
aggressiv sein
[  Musik]